[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome to Google I/O 2017.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and I'll
be here between sessions
to guide you around the
in-person experiences
at the festival.
That's right.
Even though you're
joining remotely,
this year you'll
get an in-depth look
at everything happening
on the ground.
Have a question about I/O '17?
Tweet it our way today
through the 19th,
using hashtag #io17request,
and a team of Googlers will be
on site, tracking
down answers for you.
You just saw our
developer keynote,
where Jason Titus led you
through our investments
in tools and services
for developers.
That's you.
It's our goal to simplify
repetitive tasks,
like dealing with
user login, analytics,
or synchronizing real-time data.
We're providing tools
to make it easier
to solve these and
other everyday problems
in simple and
powerful ways, and we
want to help you build
amazing new experiences
with machine learning, VR, and
voice-enabled interactions.
Let's review a handful of
the announcements you just
heard along those lines.
Android is officially supporting
the Kotlin programming
language, in addition to
the Java language and C++.
Kotlin is a brilliantly
designed, mature,
production-ready
language that we
believe will make Android
development faster and more
fun.
Android Studio 3.0
Canary is our new preview
that includes three major
features to accelerate
the development
flow, a new suite
of app performance
profiling tools
to quickly diagnose performance
issues, support for the Kotlin
programming language,
and increased gradle
build speeds for
large-sized app projects.
With Firebase, we're
providing more insights
to understand app performance
through a new product, Firebase
Performance Monitoring.
We're also introducing
integration between hosting
and cloud functions, adding
support for phone number
authentication, and
improving analytics.
Oh, and we've also started
open sourcing our SDKs.
We've introduced new
innovations for you
to make it easy for your
users to pay for services
with the Google Payment API,
to build profitable businesses
with a completely
redesigned AdMob,
and to grow a user base with
Universal App Campaigns.
There are several
powerful new features
and reports in the Play console
to help you improve your app's
performance, manage
releases with confidence,
reach a global audience,
and grow your business.
Android Instant
Apps is a new way
to run Android apps without
requiring installation.
Now anyone can build and
publish an Instant App.
There are also more
than 50 new experiences
available for users to try
out from a variety of brands,
such as Jet, New York
Times, Vimeo, and Zillow.
And finally, we're adding
two new certifications
for web developers-- the
mobile site certification
and the mobile web
specialist certification.
Those are some of
the highlights.
Check out our Google
Developers blog
for a more in-depth recap of
this afternoon's announcements.
We have 14 content tracks with
over 140 breakout sessions,
all live streamed.
And in between them all,
I'll be your all-access pass,
with Sandbox tours,
interviews, and even a peek
or two at the parties.
Tune into the live
stream on google.com/io.
Catch me in between sessions on
any of the Livestream channels,
and follow the conversation
on hashtag #io17.
This is Google I/O 2017.
[MUSIC PLAYING]